have you guys ever been to like any
other like types of festivals because I
think I feel as much as as much fun as
those summer festivals are the most fun
I've ever I've ever had at festivals are
the ones that are just [ __ ] bonkers
the penis one well the penis Festival as
well I mean I did a video on that that
was insane yeah what what is the history
behind that Festival I don't [ __ ]
know I mean it's like a fertility thing
right okay
yes to celebrate fertility and it's
basically think of like think of uh I
think the only way I can describe it
right is like so there's many of them
all over the place uh the one that I
went to I think was like the biggest one
that they do every year and it basically
starts off with like this parade on the
streets there were many penis festivals
yes yeah yeah in different parts of
Japan
no I did I thought I thought when you
said many festivals I just thought you
meant many Japanese festivals no no
there are many penis vessels throughout
the year damn they are they praying hard
to that penis yeah I do they need it
they need more they need it this is
literally like how do we stop this thing
thoughts and prayers
make sure we do something yeah so like
the one I went to was the biggest one I
forgot whereabouts it was uh somewhere
like closer to Nagoya I think oh no it
wasn't nowhere uh or aichi
um that one's wild that one was huge uh
and the and the penis yeah and like some
of these like there's basically like a
parade that happens where everyone's
like lined up on the side of the streets
and then they bring in a bunch of like
traditional
um you know penis shaped objects
and they finish it off with the
girthiest schlong I've ever seen in my
life it's this like wooden schlong I
want to guess it's maybe about 15 meters
long what carried no The Good the girth
is probably I know many people to carry
this thing like 40 guys it's like
[ __ ] Johnny Sins equivalence there's
40 guys carrying Johnny since [ __ ] and
and they and they carry it through the
the parade uh yeah I don't know at the
temple I guess she's got like a storage
unit somewhere and then they they walk
it through the parade you know people
taking photos whatever and then they
prop it up in front of the Temple
so at the end of the festival there's
just this giant 15 meter wooden [ __ ]
just just like sitting there in front of
the temple and then at the end of the
the one I went to they did this
tradition I don't know what the the the
the you know the history behind it is
but it's really dangerous and this is
the only one that they do it at uh they
what they do is they go up on these like
this giant stage that's built up about
5-10 meters tall so kind of like the one
you saw yeah at the Summer Festival
except instead of a square one it's like
a long rectangle right um and there's
about
10 15 dudes who are standing at the top
of this thing with a basket full of
Mochi
right and I'm not talking about the
squish Emoji right I'm talking about oh
like the the [ __ ] you put before it's
cooked [ __ ] in these plastic bags yeah
and what they do is they just grab
handfuls of this [ __ ] and they just
Chuck it into the crowd
and these people are just like
desperately trying to catch these Mochi
but what's really dangerous about it is
that if you're not careful because
there's literal tens of hundreds of
[ __ ] Mochi pieces yeah flying out and
these are Big these are like size of my
fist right yeah kid dies if you if
you're not careful that thing can smack
you in the [ __ ] head and it and and I
got smacked yeah you got a deck an old
grandma yeah I was I was filming it in
my video and I got decked in the [ __ ]
forehead by one I'm just like pow and
then since then he didn't watch anime
and then right back trace it back and I
was like what's anime where am I what
but I think I think the craziest one I
went to though was in nagana was that
opinions no not the penis one uh the one
I went to in Nagano was uh the fire
Festival not the fire Festival that's a
different one this won't happen not fyre
internet restoring video yeah I know
that one not fyre Festival the f-i-r-e
festival
um
yes also it's extremely dangerous okay
so basically what what they do is they
build this giant 20 25 meter wooden like
teepee looking structure right and
people are gathered all around it and
then what happens is they set it on fire
and then there are people in the back
who push the crowd towards the fire what
why
I don't know but basically if you're
standing in the front you are getting
cooked alive and you're trying to fight
back all these like people trying to
basically push you into a fight it's
like it's like Mass witch-hunting so
yeah it's like a Korean squid game we
had to get people who are broke
and I was and and mind you right this is
like there are like hundreds of people
just all gathered around and there's and
when this thing sets a blaze yeah it's
just this massive bonfire so you could
be like 20 25 meters away from this
thing and it's hot as [ __ ] yeah I can't
I can't imagine what it's like I mean
it's literally fire it's literally fire
it's like if there was a house on fire
and then someone and you were watching
it and then someone behind you was like
get close that's what it was like it's
like no I don't want to get close to
that thing it's hot
they do that for some reason I want to
say that like yeah no we don't have any
weird festivals but we have that one
where we Chase like cheese down the hill
Oh that one's the dumbest Festival
foreign
it's like the real cheese wheel rolling
Festival where you just like you they
you have a big wheel of cheese roll it
down like a very very steep hill and
they have a festival where people try to
chase the wheels whoever touches it wins
whoever touches it first wins no is
there any way you can catch up to that
thing though uh yeah there's like some
people who are in insane and literally
like throw their bodies yeah like they
don't care wow so how people normally go
is if you run fold out full speed down a
hill is normally your body can't trip
your body can't keep up with the
momentum all right so either you're
gonna fall flat on your face or you're
just gonna start rolling or most of the
time you're gonna get some kind of
broken bone or some injury because
that's what happens when you run full
force down a hill isn't that isn't that
like that scene in Bucky where he's like
full bolting it down the stairs and he's
like this is boring and he starts
yawning but there's probably one dude in
that Festival who's like that where he's
like yeah
and just all for some cheese
was it worth it was it worth the
hospital trip for that cheese I don't
know
but I never will but the part of me is
like I won't at least be there I want to
see people just like eat [ __ ] yeah well
they do I I think that's the whole point
right yeah I think that's why people
love it yeah I don't I'm pretty sure the
local government's like please can we
stop doing the cheese thing and they're
like no what's the what's the tradition
behind it though like why do they do it
oh I don't know I know it's something
that is like the the origins are very
murky yeah it's not like I feel every
Festival is like it's not it's not like
this is 100 what happened I feel like
I've heard it before because it was a
Netflix documentary about weird things
and more of the episodes is about it
because I'm yeah because I know for a
fact that in Japan at least the reason
why we do festivals or matsity is I
think like there's theories that like
they used to be used for like
sacrificial rituals and [ __ ] like that
and then one day someone was like let's
take the sacrificial part out and maybe
just like dance instead and just have a
good time having an Idol concert while
someone's getting [ __ ] sacrificed on
stage
[Laughter]
I watched a Qi thing and it was talking
about like [ __ ] uh Japanese like
celibate monks or something and they
were like they would like have to it was
wild like what they would do they it was
like saying when you were when you were
done with your duties to prove that you
were loyal to like the monk HUD you
would just trap yourself in like a
coffin for like 80 days and just die oh
you were not allowed to come out and if
you came out as a sign of weakness they
put them in like a ditch right like a
whole something like I can't remember
the exact thing but it's like what is
like the dedication yeah to this [ __ ] in
Japan is like next oh yeah because I
remember I I saw like a similar video
recently where they were talking about
this like uh I guess like type of like
monk uh training that you can do called
usheri and basically they do this thing
called the Thousand day walk and
basically what they do is every day you
walk between I think it's like 30 to 50
kilometers through the mountains and
meditate and you do that for a thousand
days but it's so hardcore that when you
sign up for this thing they actually
give you a small knife where if you
don't succeed in it you have to
literally set puku
a lot of them just like and I'm just
like bro bro like how far down do you
have to be to be like I'm gonna do this
I really want to find the celebration
it's crazy and this and it's still a
thing that they do today that's insane
yeah it's not and there are just people
who do that that's that's they literally
they literally said so you have chosen
death
it's like we will it's like would you
like to be enlightened please walk for a
thousand days straight
that's literally like a Hunter x Hunter
test you know that's uh
if by the end of the Thousand Days you
don't have men like it's not exactly
it's not worth it that's part of the
hunter exam you know you get your
hunter's license after this or you die
you know that's that's literally that's
I wouldn't be surprised if you'll get
your hunter's license some of you will
die yes someone ran a little too much
Hunter I was like yeah we can do that oh
it was tagashi and I read about that and
I was like I can put that in a hunter
sounds like a good Arc right there
that's crazy
what are you checking up trying to find
this monk thing I've definitely heard
about that celibacy thing though yeah um
that's right
is this the thing that I was talking
about Jerry okay yeah so it's basically
you you naturally mummify you yeah
that's it they mummify themselves
willingly yeah and while they're alive
and if they're like cave or like they
don't go through with it they're not
worthy but they have to like starve
themselves yeah like in a in a like
coffin yeah for like how many days is it
or something to stay in there I think
it's something crazy and I can't
remember why yeah I feel very bad that
they stood 80 80 [ __ ] days or
something to do this and I can't
remember why they did it it's like no no
maintenance it's probably something like
spiritual no it is cinnamon or something
yeah I think I remember on this queue I
think they're talking about how like
they the I think it was the Japanese
government at some point was like Hey
can you can you just stop stop doing
this please this is really weird and
uncomfortable people don't like this
yeah people don't want your mind I mean
you know you know a lot of people praise
Japan for being a few cultures that
actually really hold on to tradition but
uh I mean maybe there are some
traditions we shouldn't hold on to well
actually I mean there's a lot of
tradition they didn't preserve for some
of them they're like all right yeah this
is kind of weird modernize this thing
yeah let's let's not do that yeah penis
vessels though the people's fine as [ __ ]
I want to go through it yeah that that
just looks like a laugh it's really up
in Japan sorry and I know and I know
like in my video we also found a temple
that was dedicated to the women as well
I was gonna say I was I I was hoping it
would be yeah we found a vagina Temple
oh okay
just say vagina okay I didn't know if I
was allowed to say vagina we went to a
vagina
all right fine we went to a vagina
Temple it was awesome so as you enter
through like a a you know like a fleshy
yeah
[Music]
like the [ __ ] Predators like suit no
but what was cool was that like um it
wasn't like you know physically like
that but like it was uh symbolically the
the whole idea was that when you come
out of the temple it's like you're
rebirthing so you cleanse yourself in
the temple and then you come out of the
vagina entrance and it's like oh it's
like you're being reborn and I'm like I
thought that was pretty [ __ ] cool but
it would have been cooler if it was a
physical like
the physical parallel one you wouldn't
want that uh yeah no one wants that or
needs that I I just I just I just think
about that and I'm like yeah so like the
the idea of reborn that sounds like a
cool spiritual kind of Awakening and
idea walking out of a vagina and saying
you're like reborn that I don't know the
imagery just like the imagery just
doesn't match with the idea to me yeah
of course
I love how uh in Japan it's like you
know they have these really super
sexualized things but then they're very
hush-hush about sex and other kind of
topics oh yeah it's like weird it's like
uh it's like oh we'll have a giant
Festival celebrating penises yeah but we
don't like gays it's not gay it's not
gay things yeah that's that's what I was
wondering I was just like when I was
standing there at the penis festival and
I saw a little homerotic 40 dudes
carrying this giant [ __ ] and I'm like
wait I don't even think the Mardi Gras
does this
I'm like has anyone ever like questioned
how slightly homoerotic this is and like
Japan's making progress slowly with it
of course of course yeah I mean I think
it's just because it's it's not the I'd
say that they it's not that they don't
despise gay people right no no they just
have an old system and Japan is very
slow to change yeah but most people
don't give a [ __ ] oh no of course forget
about that sure of course and you go to
any of these sex stores bro yeah you
know I don't give a [ __ ] oh yeah if
anything they're in the future or
something yeah yeah exactly a bit too
much